let's have a look at the question and a
lot of this they don't give you a
diagram which is not very nice
but is part of the point can you
interpret what's going on
dana walks on a straight road at one
point he notices a towel
on a bearing of blah blah with a certain
angle of elevation okay so he's
he's there he looks he looks forward
that's zero degrees right where he's
going
but it's at 53 degrees true so he looks
at a certain angle he looks up there's
the tower
okay he then walks further along
and then the bearing changes and then he
looks up and the
angle of elevation is changed now just
before i draw this all up
the angle of elevation before was 21 and
now it's 26.
so what does that actually mean about
where he is in relation to the tower
he's come closer hasn't he right i
suppose if he was standing directly
beneath it the angle of relation
89 or whatever right but the whole point
is that you've got to understand wrap
your head around spatially what's taking
place
find the hydro tower all right so here's
the first tip i'm going to give you
you know how i say you draw a diagram
draw a diagram
with 3d trig you should draw two okay so
first
let's think about where he's going in 2d
space let's look down
bird's eye view and see what's going on
okay the first thing we're going to do
this is like not even a diagram this is
like pre-diagram
okay first what is the first true
bearing
okay so this is bearing one
and they say it's zero five three
degrees
okay now you spent a while thinking
about like unit circles intriguing all
that kind of thing
so you have to remember true bearings
they start from north
and then they go clockwise don't they
clockwise right so 53 degrees would be
50 3d is that way
okay so it's something like this that's
zero five three okay so that's
the direction he looks at first for the
tower when you have a look at bearing
number two
okay it's um it's whipped all the way
around it's a reflex angle 342 degrees
right 342 degrees now which way is this
draw yourself another
basic compass rose okay again we start
at north
and to be at 342 degrees
he's coming this way he's gone clockwise
all the way past
90 plus 180 past 270
and now he's in this quadrant over here
right so that angle goes all the way
around
like that in fact it's going to go a
little further
it's almost all the way up to um 360.
isn't it which would be back to north
okay so that is now the bearing the
tower is
after walking a distance right so that
angle there is 342 degrees
right so now you can see like i had to
draw this before i can put pen to paper
on like where is he going
i don't know what direction he's going
in until i can work out that's the
direction he's looking at one point
and then he's looking that way so now
roughly i'm orienting in my head
i guess he's kind of walking from left
to right
you see that right he looks at one point
and then he goes this way and now it's
over there so it's like somewhere in
here is where he's looking
okay now i just conveniently got my
compass roses in the right spot but it
might not always be like that if these
were swapped around
you have to think which way is you
actually walking
so now i'm going to do my bird's eye
diagram and i guess it looks something
like this
there you go okay so there's uh there's
david
one that's where he starts there's david
ii and here is the tower
okay so this is all just in 2d space
right
before i leave this i'm going to use my
understanding of these angles here
to put angles inside the triangle okay
we'll start with the first one that
one's easy
see there's 53 degrees going that way
right so what's this angle
inside the triangle
it'll be the um the complement of 53
because it sounds it's this guy here
isn't it
right so that makes it i think 37 that's
what i heard
37 degrees that's in there okay
in here to get this angle where is this
angle on my compass rose
it's on there isn't it it's there right
so it goes
90 180 270 is that three quarters way
around the circle
so what's left is 72 degrees
is that all right you see what's going
on so now
using this before i leave this diagram i
just might as well finish this diagram
while i'm there
what's the last angle angles on the
triangle 71 right
71. okay so this is good
i've got this um
top down right oh one thing i'm missing
how far do you walk again
do you think where is that is d1d2 isn't
it
230 meters great
okay so there's our first diagram right
and look like we haven't even started
solving the question the real
challenge of this question is here it's
not in the trig the trig is easy
it's like it's like two three lines it's
three lines of tree
it's all in understanding especially
what's going on
any questions so far okay now what i'm
going to do is
i am going to take this and now i'm
going to look at it from an angle
because i need to put height on there i
need to draw a 3d diagram after this
so i've got d1 still going to d2
okay and i've got the tower over there
but the tower
goes up right so now i've kind of got
flat ground here
and here's the tower like up this way as
is vertical
okay so now the diagram i drew before
has t on the ground i'm looking down
right so the tower is just a point in
space
but here now i've got the top of the
tower in here right
so i've got one angle of elevation right
and then i've got another one over there
now here's one of the benefits of doing
two diagrams right
not only can i really understand what's
going on here
but because i've got all this
information on this diagram i'm not
gonna cloud it on this diagram
right i'm going to use this strictly to
store like up down information
and not worry about this other stuff
which i've got more clearly illustrated
elsewhere
so what are the angles of elevation we
said they go from 21 degrees
21 degrees this is first angle of
elevation
and then 26 degrees
okay so where is 37 37 is an angle
on the ground right it would be here
but i don't want to put it in you see
what i mean
okay we don't i didn't i didn't draw it
as east like it's just a straight line
i suppose i could have drawn at an angle
but it'll just like it could be going up
like that
but it doesn't make a difference to how
i actually solve the question
okay so stay with me guys stay with me
what i've got here this is my bird's eye
view right so this is looking
this is looking directly on top so this
is a 2d diagram
this is my 3d diagram you have a fancy
name for this i've heard you guys
some of you mentioned it it's called an
isometric diagram right
isometric diagrams are very hard to draw
well
especially when and this is what like 99
students do
they try and do their bird's eye diagram
on the same diagram
as their isometric one so they've got
bearings happening here and it's just
confusing like crazy okay so that's all
the information i'm going to put on
there
for now yeah but if you use your job as
part of working out would it be better
to put everything on the desktop
this is my working app so that's fine
and i would argue
that this is 10 times clearer than any
diagram where everyone tries to put
everything on
this well no i plan to show you a method
that's really really doggy and we'll get
you zero marks
this this is all my work again which is
why by the way when people ask me for
working out paper like i've said this
before right
you shouldn't have working out paper an
answer paper you're working out is your
answer okay it's all there like i'd
present all of this
okay can we keep going yep all right
now i'm after a height i'm after a
height
where is the height i'm after there it's
not on this diagram is it right
because this is a 2d diagram it's over
here
it's there that's h okay
now look at this right i'm after a
height
that's a length i don't know anything on
this diagram about
lengths except for a single number
right that's the only length i have on
this diagram right
so clearly i must go from here from this
diagram where there's the length i want
i've got to transmit something from here
over to here where there's a length i
can
use does that make sense right so i have
to know okay now
watch this is the way i'm going to do it
okay i've got to go from here
3d isometric over to bird's eye view
right and get this information over
there
so clearly i'm going to need i'll put in
another color
i'm going to need this side here
and i'm going to need this side
here can you see why because those sides
are on this diagram
there they are right best investment you
can bring into an exam after a template
and a calculator
is a set of color pencils okay or
highlight as well okay
well
highlighters are to help you understand
what's going on
right they would be marked but they does
this not make them clearer it doesn't
matter
all right now these are the lengths i'm
after
okay what are they actually equal to
well i've got
a height here i have a length here this
is a right angle triangle right
in fact i've got two of them yes because
it's an angle of elevation
okay so i've got an angle an opposite
side and i want
an adjacent side right like look at this
length up in here it's no use you can
ignore it why
think about it it has it has nothing to
do with getting over here
that's not going to help you so i want
opposite and adjacent together that's
going to be
tan okay so i'm going to do it like this
because in my head
to trim down as much as in the diagram
as possible you'll see i'm going to go
to a direct step which might be a bit
confusing
so i've got a red side okay okay
now in this triangle this right angle
triangle here
tan 21 10 21 is opposite on adjacent
it's h over red right
so if i want red i'm going to have to
swap these guys right you see that
10 21 is gonna go on the denominator
okay
so this is in fact is going to be to
write it in the most concise way
h caught 21. okay
you're going to see cot a lot when
you're doing these angular inclination
3d tree questions okay using exactly the
same logic this green guy over here
right that's hot 26.
so far so good okay now i've got all i
need and i can forget
this is a 3d question now because i can
come over to my 2d diagram
h cot 26 h
cart 21. right
and i've got all i need to work out